>> Dagen: THE COVINGTON
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT WHO WAS THE
CENTER OF A CONFRONTATION WITH
THE NATIVE AMERICAN ACTIVIST
BACK IN JANUARY IS AGAIN GOING
AFTER THE MEDIA.
FRESH OFF THE HEELS OF A LAWSUIT
FILED LAST MONTH AGAINST
"THE WASHINGTON POST, THE
HIGH SCHOOLER IS PLANNING TO SUE
CNN FOR MORE THAN $250 MILLION.
HERE'S HIS LAWYER.
>> CNN WAS PROBABLY MORE VICIOUS
IN ITS DIRECT ATTACKS ON
NICHOLAS THAN
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
NICHOLAS SANDMANN DID ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING WRONG.
CNN COULDN'T RESIST THE IDEA
THAT HERE IS A YOUNG BOY WITH A
MAKE AMERICA GREAT AGAIN CAP ON.
THEY ARE OUT THERE RIGHT AWAY
GOING AFTER THIS YOUNG BOY, AND
THEY MAINTAIN IT FOR AT LEAST
TWO DAYS.
WHY DIDN'T THEY STOP AND TAKE AN
HOUR AND LOOKED THROUGH THE
INTERNET AND FIND THE TRUTH AND
THEN REPORT IT.
MAYBE DO THAT BEFORE YOU REPORT
THE LIES.
>> Dagen: MAY BE DO THAT
BEFORE YOU REPORT THE LIES,
GREG.
DO THEY HAVE A CASE?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW BUT THE
LAWSUIT IS NECESSARY BECAUSE CNN
IS INCAPABLE OF LEARNING.
THEY REPEAT THE SAME MISTAKES
WHICH ARE THESE DIVISIVE EFFORTS
TO CANCEL PEOPLE OUT.
IF I WERE AT CNN, IF I WAS JEFF
ZUCKER, I WOULD SIT EVERYBODY
DOWN AND SAY DO YOU WANT TO BE
PART OF THIS NEW TREND OF
BASICALLY PUBLICLY BLACKLISTING
PEOPLE, RUINING THEIR LIVES.
IF NO ONE HAD PUT THE BRAKES ON
THIS, THAT KID'S LIFE WOULD HAVE
BEEN RUINED AND ANYBODY WHO
HAPPENED TO BE A TRUMP SUPPORTER
WOULD BE NEXT.
CONSIDER HOW THIS WOULD'VE
TURNED OUT IF THERE WASN'T OTHER
VIDEO.
CNN NEVER WOULD'VE TAKEN A
BREATH.
THEY MOVED ON FROM COVINGTON TO
SMOLLETT AND EVEN IF YOU GO BACK
A FEW YEARS, THEIR ANTIPOLICE
NARRATIVE, THEY COULD HAVE
LEARNED FROM THAT BUT THEY
DIDN'T.
SO THIS BANISHMENT CRAZE THEY
ARE ON AND WHAT THEY COULD HAVE
DONE TO THIS KID, EVEN IF THE
LAWSUIT IS WITHOUT MERIT OR
WHATEVER, MAYBE IT WOULD CAUSE
THEM TO SIT DOWN AND THINK ABOUT
IT.
DO YOU WANT TO BE PART OF THIS
MOB, THIS NEW TREND, OR DO YOU
WANT TO SIT BACK AND THINK ABOUT
WHAT YOU'RE DOING?
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TO
YOU.
>> Dana: I AM NODDING.
I AM AGREEING.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" WAS ALSO
SUED BY THE SAME GROUP BEFORE ON
BEHALF OF THE YOUNG MAN.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" PUBLISHED
AN EDITOR'S NOTE THAT SAID WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
WE SHOULD HAVE DONE MORE
REPORTING.
THEY ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS IT SO
WHEN IT GOES IN FRONT OF THE
JUDGE AND THEY MIGHT SAY THERE'S
NO STANDING HERE.
I AM WITH GREG.
I DON'T KNOW HOW IT WILL TURN
OUT IN COURT BUT IF THEY HAVE
NOT FILED A LAWSUIT, NOBODY
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT THIS.
LAWSUIT STRIVE FOR COVERAGE AND
NEWS.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T GET
$250 MILLION FROM CNN OR
"WASHINGTON POST" OR WHATEVER,
PUTTING IT OUT THERE FOR ALL OF
US TO TALK ABOUT IS WORTHWHILE.
>> Dagen: THE MONEY AMOUNTS
ARE MEANT TO SEND A MESSAGE.
TWO MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS, LIKE
YOUR JOURNALISTS SHOULD BE
BELCHING FILE ON SOCIAL MEDIA,
PART OF THE MOB, WHEN THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW IT'S TRUE.
IN THE LAWSUIT FILED AGAINST
"WASHINGTON POST," IT SAID ONE
OF THE REPORTERS THERE WHO
WORKED ON THE STORY LATER
RETWEETED THE SHORTENED VIDEO
WHICH BASICALLY TOLD A STORY
THAT WAS NOT TRUE.
>> Jesse: I AM SURE ZUCKER
SENT OUT A FEW MEMOS TELLING
EVERYBODY THAT CHECKED
THEMSELVES ON SOCIAL MEDIA OR
ELSE THEY ARE GOING TO COST THE
COMPANY OF FORTUNE.
I'VE MADE A FEW GAFFES IN MY
CAREER.
CNN POINTS FINGERS AND LAUGH AND
THEY MOCK BUT AT LEAST I'M NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR A QUARTER OF A
BILLION DOLLAR LAWSUIT.
BY SMEARING A MINOR.
YOU ARE, NOT ME.
CNN IS PRETTY COCKY.
THEY ARE IN THIRD PLACE.
I THINK HALF THE COUNTRY THINKS
THEY ARE FAKE NEWS AND NOW THEY
ARE FACING A MULTIMILLION DOLLAR
LAWSUIT.
WHAT THEY'VE DONE NOW, AND TO
GREG'S POINT WHICH I THINK IS A
GREAT ONE, THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY TARGET POPULAR
PEOPLE, FAMOUS PEOPLE, TALENTED
POLITICIANS.
THEY GO AFTER THE LITTLE GUY.
>> Greg: REMEMBER THE WOMAN
WHO GOT THE RUSSIAN BOT AND THEY
ANSWERED IT AND THEY CORNERED
HER.
>> Jesse: THEY GO AFTER
ANONYMOUS PEOPLE.
THEY UNMASK RANDOM PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THE GUY WHO DID THE
FUNNY VIDEO ON YOUTUBE OF THE
BODY SLAM.
THEY GO AFTER MINORS.
THAT'S BULLYING.
THEY CALL OUT THE BULLIES.
THEY ARE THE BULLIES.
>> Dagen: ARE THE PEOPLE OVER
THERE SO IRRETRIEVABLY STUPID
THAT THEY DON'T KNOW TO TAKE A
BREATH?
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GO AFTER A
TEENAGER, HIGH SCHOOL JUNIOR,
NOT A PUBLIC FIGURE BUT A
PRIVATE FIGURE WITH SOMETHING IF
YOU DON'T HAVE THE WHOLE STORY.
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO LAMBASTE
THIS KID AND TRY TO DESTROY HIS
LIFE?
DON'T THEY HAVE ONE BREATH OF
REVELATION THAT THEY SHOULDN'T
DO THAT?
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS A
MERITLESS LAWSUIT AND I THINK
THIS KID IS BEING USED BY THE
RIGHT AND I DON'T KNOW WHO THIS
LAWYERS BUT IT SOUNDS TO ME LIKE
THERE'S A GRAVY TRAIN NOW.
"WASHINGTON POST," CNN.
HE'S BECOME A HERO WHO ASSOCIATE
THIS WITH ANY MEDIA INJUSTICE
AGAINST THE FAR RIGHT AND
AGAINST TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
THE KEY FOR ME IS --
>> Dagen: I'M SORRY.
CNN AND ALL THESE NEWS
ORGANIZATIONS DID THIS TO ME AND
TOLD A STORY ABOUT ME AND
BASICALLY RAIN HELLFIRE DOWN AT
ME AND MY FAMILY AND ALL OF MY
BUDDIES IN SCHOOL, MY BACKSIDE
WOULD BE PRETTY CHAPPED TOO TO
THE TUNE OF SO FAR HAVE A
BILLION DOLLARS.
>> Juan: NO, YOU WOULDN'T.
I THINK IF YOU FELT THAT WAY,
DAGEN, YOU WOULD SAY I WANT THIS
OVER AND I WANT PEOPLE TO KNOW
THEY WERE WRONG.
GIVE ME A SECOND.
HERE'S THE THING.
THEY DIDN'T CREATE THIS TAPE.
THIS TAPE COME FROM SOMEBODY ON
THE INTERNET THAT THE GOVERNMENT
STILL DOESN'T KNOW EXACTLY WHO
THEY ARE BUT THEY COULD HAVE
BEEN THE RUSSIANS, WHATEVER,
TIED TO BRAZIL.
THAT'S THAT SOURCE OF THIS TAPE
AND THEN IN THE SOCIAL MEDIA AGE
WHEN THE TAPE GETS OUT THERE,
EVERYBODY SAYS OF USING THIS
TAPE AND YOU GET PEOPLE LIKE CNN
ON "THE WASHINGTON POST"
REACTING.
>> Dagen: NO, NO, NO.
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THEY'LL LEARN.
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY EXTERNAL --
THE ONLY EXTERNAL BREAKS YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE HER FROM PEOPLE